[Music]
10's Mac we're gonna do a nice photo
test and I'm so excited about this
because one of the newer things because
this has the a12 Bionic chip that chip
is much faster than the previous version
so what that means is there's a lot of
new enhancements other than yes it will
speed up things make your app something
faster but there are camera enhancements
as well there's super HDR which it
basically will take a bunch of photos as
soon as you hit that shutter button
it'll then take all of those photos
consisting of high contrast photos low
light a bunch of different pictures and
they take them all and English them all
together to take one beautiful photo so
let's take a picture here as a test so
what's really cool about this is as you
can see here in real life not on the
phone there's a lot of different things
going on there's a lot of bright
sunlight there's a lot of contrasting
shadows and most of the times when you
would take this type of photo something
would probably be blown out look at that
super crisp so it's so crispy Oh Jen let
me take a picture of you one two three
you look great what's that right there
no that's too much work but I can't take
another picture so let's try to take a
live photo as well just start moving
around a little so it's cool because
when you swipe up this will give you all
of the options and things that you can
do you can do live look at you dancin
I'm kind of getting into live photo you
could do a loop wait look at this it
knew it was you
so much like the iPhone 10 these rear
cameras are both 12 megapixels but
what's new in the iPhone 10s Max and the
10s is it has a different sensor so that
allows for faster autofocus and better
low-light photos so I mean you can
already see how quick this focus is like
look focus its focus already it's so
quick oh my goodness so you can also do
portrait mode on the front-facing and on
the back facing I took the picture there
she is
so before I show you this guys I'm
already gonna just say that taking the
portrait photos it seems so much faster
it's really snappy like that
snappy studio light natural light but
let's show you this this is the
adjustable aperture so we return it all
the way down and then slowly turn it all
the way up all the way down all the way
up
so now let's tie the back facing
portrait mode do you can you do both
that's what kind of see how it did so
here it is at 4.5 all the way up all the
way back down it's kind of crazy because
you can just see it happening right
before your eyes and it's super quick
the front-facing camera now shoots 60
frames a second and it's 1080p we are
now testing out the front-facing video
there's Jana hello where'd you go there
you are but this is just regular 1080p
at front-facing camera and it already
seems to be way more steady okay cool
let's play this back and see what it
looks like this looks pretty good it's
crazy dude could you notice the stereo
sound how different it sounds now with
stereo sound so movies or films or
videos that you record on your phone or
other videos that are stereo you'll be
able to hear it in stereo play the new
co-lead song it sounds so good
[Music]
okay so now I'm in the camera settings
I'm gonna switch this to 4k 24 frames a
second because that's what I'm actually
shooting this video on slo-mo 1080p 240
so we will test that out after we test
this back facing camera that lens flare
JJ Abrams's please call me or tweet me I
prefer I prefer JJ Abrams is my hero
let's look at it so most of the time on
these types of videos my audio I usually
just make mono but I want to show you
guys what this sounds like when it is in
stereo so now I'm gonna be in front of
it
hello hello hello I'm over here I'm over
here hello hello hello I am now over
here hello no this is such a riveting
gob day how see something I just got hit
by a giant leaf but leave really big
super massive you tell me honestly if
I've ever seen I'm pretty surprised how
good this is looking I uh I'm so excited
okay we're gonna do some slow-mo hair
flips are you ready are you gonna be
able to do both at the same time you're
so skilled does this look good
I think I pulled something those fresh
locks super luscious look at this face
aha this little boy looks so good
the Sun is blurring down on my face so
I'm gonna take a picture of Jenna that
would normally be super backlit but with
the new super HDR it should even
everything out pretty well
Wow you look like a freaking angel look
at you Wow
this is where you're like stop talking I
was like so I don't know how Jenna does
it but she is like such an incredible
iPhone photographer like we could be
looking at the same scene and no matter
what the picture that she takes ends up
being better than everybody else's
let's grab the jeong-do John let's go
so this is gonna be the perfect spot to
test out the new extended dynamic range
in the video right now the video that
you're actually watching is taken with
the iPhone 10's max the audio I'm
stealing from the log microphone that
I'm using we're gonna take some photos
we're gonna take some video perhaps some
jumpin shots Jenna is the jumpin shot
Queen so I guess let's go
[Music]
hey Jen we're gonna test your work let's
see what we've got all right look at
this detail I know but this is my first
one that was your first one it still
looks really good though what we're
looking at here is this normally would
be super backlit you wouldn't even be
able to see any detail in me I would
just be a shadow so I want to say it's
all you but it's also the foam these are
so good Wow photo credit oh my gosh I
look like a model look at this do you
see that it captured the hair movement
everyone can be a model with the iPhone
10 us
[Music]
you know there's a dog swings right yeah
but there's people over there so can you
get a slow-mo of me swinging
okay I don't fit in here
I'm so talented
[Music]
this
you can get some cool shots here god I
love churros
[Music]
[Applause]
oh boy we are on the ride every time I
get on here I wonder why did I do this
it takes a really long time you end up
being on your hurt ever we're gonna ride
the roller coaster next whoa I don't
like Heights
Wow whoa
look in this picture
[Music]
hashtag shot on iphone
well this is a cool shot too
having some video
so here is a little video this is on the
front facing camera we are now on the
ferris wheel
here's some shots from the ferris wheel
directly from with the iPhone tennis
match
[Music]
I think the front-facing video looks way
better correct me if I'm wrong
time to ride the coaster studies limo
coaster probably
okay succeed
let's look at the iPhone 10's I have so
much fun making this video I have a
bunch more iPhone videos coming for you
guys so stay tuned if you're not
subscribed be sure to subscribe and of
course hit the bell I just realized I
think the phone that I was holding up
was my old iPhone 10 it wasn't even in
it was just your head okay good
[Music]